uh what's going on guys
what's going on
I see you guys
I see you guys everyone's in the chat
man it's been a minute
it's been a minute I'm hoping everyone
can hear me fine I don't expect this to
be long
doing a little bit of a solo stuff you
know I I'm hoping I got someone that's
popping through here
they ain't here yet but I'm hoping
they'll be here I'm hoping
so we we got a little bit yeah happy New
Years guys Happy New Year's everyone in
the chat Happy New Years
we got some stuff to talk about today
I saw people already in the chat talking
about it
look
all your answers will be heard
yeah happy New Year guys it's it's been
a
one hell of a year
it's been one hell of a year
and good and bad you know I don't think
it's been a bad year uh it's definitely
been an interesting year
I think that's the better word for it an
interesting year
you know this is just pretty much like a
talking to you guys you know a little
bit
a little bit of a
we're gonna we're just gonna chat it up
man we're gonna chat it up there's a lot
of stuff that has been going on over the
break
that I'm very interested in
and I want to talk about it
and I see people in the chat bringing up
the
yeah it's been pretty good man it's been
pretty good
you know I figured I'd give you guys a
little bit of entertainment on the New
Year's because I know it's been dry out
there I know it's been dry
I figured I'd give you guys a little bit
entertainment you know we can we can
socialize we can exchange notes
you know what you guys been playing what
you guys been playing I I played an
absurd amount of Tactics Ogre like an
absurd amount of tax so girl hold up
oh
[Music]
like a ridiculous amount of toxic Soaker
and when I say ridiculous I mean
ridiculous
what's up going on guys what's going on
Gotham Knights you know I'm not saying
Gotham Knights is in that game
it's just not that game for me
it's not that game for me man it's not
that game for me
this year can't wait for Street Fighter
Tekken Elder Elder Elder ring and
cyberpunk keep trying that new expansion
stuff vampire Survivor
and let's go happy New Years chat Happy
New Years
Stellar blade that's out
I didn't know it was out
back for blood it's a good game
you know this technically ain't really
an attic show you know I feel like I
should call these diff for something
different
it's like an it it's like like a hosho
or a talk show
you know you guys got me until until my
food gets here
I don't know how long that will be but
you have me until my food gets here
probably got me maybe
40 minutes
because my brother takes forever to do
anything
he'll take forever to go get my food
forever ever and ever
look what I found though guys I found
like one of these things
it's the um
like the Genji things
yeah I found one of those
put them on the grill nah
also picked up that deep rock I used to
try that game I did try that game out
once
I heard Starfield June I'm thinking more
July chat I'm thinking more July uh you
know we'll get to that here in a second
um
I'm hoping I'm wrong but for some reason
I'm thinking July that that's what I'm
thinking
could be wrong
I I'm not the holder of information
I don't know everything I do know a
little bit of stuff that I I don't I'm
not gonna talk about because
you know there's certain things that you
can that you can easily talk about not
really bother anyone or get anyone in
trouble
and then there's certain things that you
really should keep close to your chest
I I do have a uh have you used an elite
controller core you mean this
yeah Microsoft sent me that's the first
accessory that Microsoft has sent IOP
that's the first accessory that
Microsoft has ever sent us and you know
I do think they're solid controllers but
they need to be restructured to be more
durable
I I like it but I do like I said like I
feel like it needs to be better made
because I'm not having like serious
issues but I can tell that you know I
will start having issues with this
control in probably six months to a year
but the good thing is like the majority
of the controller is is replaceable
so you know that that's always a good
thing but I I like the feel of it I like
the feel of it
how is Chained Echo I've been playing
trained Echoes for a minute now
hold up
hold up guys
oh my God why does people have to
do work when I'm streaming you know they
they won't do nothing this whole time
but the moment I start streaming
everyone got to do everything known to
man
this light is baller maybe I need to
turn this light down a little bit
just a little bit
do you guys hear that that sound
uh hellblade in September
I'd be surprised
I don't think it's like not doable I
think it's possible
but not likely what's up Jacob
well they went up that way now they're
not necessarily near me anymore but
oh my
but they they are being a little
ridiculous they're being a little
ridiculous
all right so let's get on with the show
man let's get on with the show we got 48
people 55 people in here man hit that
like button let's get that as high as we
possibly can you know it's gonna be a
solo show we're gonna go through these
topics and get up out of here uh you
know I told I offered some people to
come through but it's a holiday man you
know I got to give people that off
season man got to give people that off
season they'll be back
next week we'll be back in full
run and I might try to bring someone
else on the show too but we'll see
so there's things that we can talk about
I feel like first thing let's talk about
is
oh my God hold up my brother's calling
me
hello
yes yummy Japan
and would you would you kill me if I
asked you stop and get me a Baja Blast
but I will send you fifteen dollars
all right bye-bye
all right sorry about that sorry about
that guys
all right so let's let's talk about well
I don't even know when the show started
we about eight minutes in
the show started literally when the like
immediately I didn't do a starting Zoom
screen
did that like right off the bat
so we got nine minutes
and we'll say yeah nine minutes is fine
let's talk about 20 22 and 2023. any
good guests coming to IOP this year when
is Phil coming to the show oh
Phil coming to the show
I'm not gonna
I will say that we are
we are attempting to get that in the
books
I'm not going to really go into detail
on when we're tempting but it is
something that we're really going to
push this year
but I don't know if it's gonna happen
because you know man's busy he's busy I
don't know if it's gonna happen
but we will do the best we can for for
the realm you know the best we can
you don't need to get Jim Ryan on the
show that would be legendary once if we
get Jim Ryan and
Phil Spencer at the same time
you know it obviously that would never
happen
but what I would like to do is I would
like to have
a lead developer
an in like
Ryan McCaffrey
uh or someone that's like a lead a lead
developer uh shout out to
I'm sorry man I'm gonna call you bang
all right because I ain't butchering
your name man but welcome to Welcome to
the real man welcome to
uh to Silver
yeah just an ad extreme people might
show up you know I I'm I'm not easy to
what's what I'm looking for I'm not easy
to
to predict you know people might show up
in here
so a show that I would love to do and
tell me chat if this is going to be a
good show
is imagine having someone from
digital Foundry on
someone from like a lead developer
and someone and like
someone like Ryan McCaffrey like a huge
influence like a huge journalist and
like an influencer and the whole show
would be to like
the direction that the information goes
from the developer making it
to the journalists that cover it
to the influencers that cover it from
the journalist's info because a lot of
the things feed down from the
journalists like they get a lot of
firsts
and I would like to do something like
that I would like to do something like
that that would be a hard stream to like
set up though
wouldn't be easy
all right sorry about that guys
I think that would be a nice little
interview I think people would like that
I really do I think people would like
that
uh but you know what answer some of the
questions I see you guys got you know um
I have been playing
I have been playing
chained echoes
now
I'm not gonna go too into into big
detail because I do want to review the
game
uh but so far so good that's all that
that's what I will say so far so good
yeah uh unfortunately
we did get two people on from obsidian
one of them went to Activision so that
that's interesting one of them went to
yeah but see
Lydia master I probably butchered your
name my bad
that's the reason we bring these people
into these perspectives to get their
opinion on stuff that we don't exactly
agree on now I did want to stream high
on life
but King really was pushing against it
because it's got a lot of
variables that he didn't feel
comfortable being on the IOP stream like
the IOP Channel which you know I for one
don't really necessarily care about
stuff like that but
for my brand Logistics I can understand
where they're coming from
if that makes sense to you guys
all right so
Echo Chambers good Echo chain good I
think you know so far so good I'm not
too far into it maybe five ten hours if
that
and it's been an interesting interesting
thing I think some of you will like
especially if you like that 16 bit and
now it doesn't have voice acting and you
guys know how I am if you've seen any of
my reviews you know that I'm very
against not having voice acting but I'm
a little bit more Ling it when it comes
to developers like small time developers
because I know that's not something
that's easy or cheap to do so as long as
you have a reason not to be doing voice
acting
then I I'm 100 with it uh this is a
small team
and
I do understand why some people
why they couldn't afford voice acting
part of me is just like
like just let the developers do it man
like I feel like there's such a huge
pool of people that want to get into the
voice acting scene that would probably
do voice acting on small indie games for
a little bit of nothing just to get
their name out there I don't know how
the voice acting thing goes here here's
the plans that I have for IOP
all right because we we do want to
expand in certain areas and one of the
biggest things that I personally want to
do is I want to get more voice actors on
I want to get more of a
of a role going into that I want to
interview more people in the aspect of
what's going on in the industry and
voice acting is one of the fields that I
want to go into
but the question is is like can we
effectively put them on the IOP podcast
I pardon me feels like no
I think the best thing to do with some
of these smaller uh you know interviews
is to just go because the problem is
when they come on IOP there's a lot of
there's a lot of like red tape when it
comes to stuff like that you know when
we have certain topics certain people
feel uncomfortable doing that so I feel
like just a base interview is better
than having them come on a podcast if
that makes sense to you guys because if
I'm asking for a certain
developer or a certain voice actor come
on and they see okay but you guys are
talking about you know topics that they
might feel a little bit more
inclined not to come on because they
don't want to be in a scenario with
those topics now you guys know that we
don't force our guests to stay on
they're free to leave after the intros
but some people don't know that
they think they have to leave when the
show's over
so you know I want to do a little bit
more on that you know I want to do more
voice acting uh interview well I want to
get into the voice acting interviews I
want to interview more developers I I
want to do a lot more in 2023. you know
chained Echo I would like to get the
people that reviewed that on the channel
That made that on the channel
I think I think that is something that
I'm really going to strive for this year
who did the voices
yeah I I
I'm very curious
you know I think
I think we need to you know I'm gonna
really push using this platform to
explain to people how the industry works
and I think we can do a better job on
that you guys know what I'm saying like
we do a lot of talking about how
Microsoft's doing what the Activision
deal or how this person's doing with
that deal but I feel like there's not a
lot of talking on how the actual
industry works and I felt like we can do
better
you know we need to educate our viewers
on not just
the stuff that's going on oh out in the
open but you know stuff that's going on
in the industry as well
you know and I want to I want to use our
platform for better stuff than that I
really do I feel like
we definitely have the opportunity and
that's why I want them to not be part of
the the podcast you know they're going
to be on the channel
but they're not going to be a part of
the podcast I I I'm very big on that
because I want I want to have an
interviewing scene now you've seen me
interview a couple people last year I
did lose two of them because my hard
drive corrupted
but
what I want to do this year is I want to
do more of that I want to get more
people on here I want to talk about you
know just the the struggles in the
industry not just as a developer I want
to have more real conversations I want
to talk to more people that actually are
in the development tool of the the
industry itself
you know I'm I love talking to
influencers I love talking to
journalists but I want to talk more
about the people that's actually making
it and I think I think that's important
so let's talk about 2022 and 2023
all right so a little bit how would you
guys feel 2022 went do you guys think it
was a good year for games like let's
let's be honest here do you guys think
that
2022 was a good year in games I think it
was an okay year but I don't think it
was like an amazing year or anything and
maybe it's because there wasn't that
that killer game besides Elden ring
that was like yo this is it like this is
what we play games for uh but I think it
was good I think it was a fantastic year
it just I don't I don't think it was
like yo
whoa I don't think it was that
I think 2023
is going to be special
and I think a lot of these games
have been already pushed back where I
don't see them being pushed back again
you know I think for the majority of the
time these games are coming out in 2023
and I think that's good
um I think that's
we need more release dates on some of
these obviously
but I'm going to be interested man I
really I really feel like we got
something going guys Chad realm we had
we we had a good thing going last year
uh we had a fantastic milestones and you
know we kind of took it easy the last
couple months because you know we feel
like
we had to get back to Our Roots because
we just we're having too many guests on
and I think some of you in the chat can
agree that
we do better when it's just us and we
have people cameo in
because I feel like the energy is more
in there you know we we have more fun
because we're talking about you know the
topics that us personally brought into
into there so you know that we're still
gonna have guests going into 2023 but
we're going to try to keep it more of us
and then sprinkle the guest in uh and
plus
you guys know how we are we we always
try to highlight
influencers smaller influencers that
that need more of that shine
so we're obviously going to do that too
we're going to make sure that we give a
platform to people that have really
worked hard
and they need a little bit more of
exposure and we're going to do we're
gonna do better on that too
for Xbox they better they can't have
another year like this especially at the
end of the year and how they went
totally silent yeah I agree you know
I feel like the gaming industry was good
this year but Xbox was lacking
uh they need to do better next year I
personally didn't even feel like
Game Pass was the greatest this year you
know that's just me
uh that is just me
said maybe two guests a show a month and
two IOP only shows
um
I think what I got some guests that I
personally want on you know put in the
chat guess that you guys would want on
curious to hear you guys opinion on that
put in the chat
some guess that you would personally
like to see on IOP
so I could get with Cog and we could try
to reach out to some of these people
because we we've gotten to the point
where it's hard to get a hold of some of
these people now
you know we've gotten bigger because of
the
the traffic that you guys give us you
guys give us some form of numbers so we
can take
those numbers to other people to get
them on uh I I get that um VAR like we
definitely don't need guests I
understand that but I like to guess man
I I do I like the guys I like to get
perspectives of other people in the
industry
that that's the biggest thing I like
doing I like getting perspectives of
other influencers other journalists just
other people in general in the in in the
industry I like that
you show a live Supremacy happy New Year
happy New Year guys Happy New Year [ __ ]
Jay
John Wismer probably butcher Dylan B
Dark Side 1923 I'm not sure what
everyone else was doing on Xbox I never
said said solid year old year
mvg no we're not getting mvg
having some guests gives you clout
um it's not necessarily about the clout
um I it is nice to have bigger guests on
to give us exposure to newer communities
but we don't need that you know we
we we care more about giving you guys a
good show you know and there's been
opportunities we could have had massive
guests on that we decided not to pursue
because it wasn't a good fit for us
and we care more about making sure it's
a good fit for us
than we care about
okay sorry that we care about having
numbers you know we want to make sure
you guys enjoy the show
and uh you know we could definitely get
Luke on uh James Arnold Taylor let me
copy that Jacob
I wonder if like there's an agent I can
reach using this info
I don't know
all right
we want Sarah Vaughn we promise to
behave
um we've tried man
we've reached out before just timing
doesn't
go along with this you know when it
comes to people like that it's hard to
get the timing right
and we will continue trying
uh but you know we we definitely are
looking to get some of that bring on
some hot tub streamers no no no no thank
you Matt booty
you know I
I don't know part of me
Matt Booty like I don't want here's the
thing
Matt Booty's a cool guy but I don't want
someone that's going to come on the
podcast and just PR Spinners all day
and I feel like Matt booty is like king
of PR you know
we get it Game Pass is doing good we we
get this and maybe we just need to wait
more for actual info to come out
but
we just gotta wait for that you know we
gotta wait for more info so they can
actually talk about stuff
and I think that's the biggest thing
that I
need to be more patient with is waiting
for more info to come up because
what's the point in getting someone like
Phil Spencer on or something and they
can't really talk about anything
they just PR spin over and over again
and I think that is one of the biggest
things that you know we want to have a
good show for you guys and if we bring
someone on that they just say we can't
talk about that you know or PR speak I
don't think that's a good show you know
obviously we would so celebrate these
people if they came on uh but I yeah I
think Aaron grieber will be a good guest
because he he's got Charisma he's got a
lot of energy so I think he would be a
good guest
but he he's marketing and and you know
nothing against marketing or anything
like that but
it's just it's just like such great
areas if you guys get what I'm saying
like
you know
I don't want to get someone on that's
just going to push this product either
and I feel like Aaron Greenberg's cool
dude but you know he's marketing it's
his job
uh can we get God Howard on the show
that would be epic that would be cool
I guess we could we could reach out to
Microsoft and see if we can set
negotiations to try to get talk Howard
around Starfield
so I you know I'm not saying that's
something that's out of an ordinary
we might be able to make that happen I
don't know you guys know how it is with
this stuff man Ed boom from netherrealm
I think Coggin them would like that
it's just getting a hold of these people
you know you guys we got 144 people in
here hit that like button you know you
guys give us the numbers we need to go
to these people but if you can't get a
hold of them it's hard
a lot of these people don't check their
DMS and some of them have open DMS but
we they still don't check them or they
just leave us on red and they don't care
you know
a lot of different issues in the
industry man a lot of different issues
so that's pretty much all we're going to
talk about when it comes to you know
2022 2023 I think we got a lot of good
stuff coming and I think you guys are
going to really enjoy the show that
we're going to put on
um you know we always do what we can
let's put 28 minutes and then we're
gonna we're gonna get to this Xbox event
that's what we're going to talk about
this Xbox event all right so chat
put in the chat put in the comment
section give me dates and months when
you think this Xbox event's gonna be
tell me dates and months put it in the
chat tell me a date
in a month and I'm gonna come back here
and I'm gonna see who was right
February I need a date with that man
26th of January
March I hope it's not March that'd be
horrible February
14th oh that's that's that's a a bold
statement January the 26th February the
14th
foreign
we need that date with the February the
3rd January the 20th February the 6th oh
two sixes January the 31st January the
30th
not till spring added do you think
they'll announce the family playing game
pass at the event I don't know I think
they might save that for when they raise
the prices on um on Game Pass if that
happens this year then
it's possible February the 21st February
the 4th
um
I'm a I'm gonna lean towards for
everywhere I think what early February
is when we'll probably see this now I
don't
I don't know what to degrade this event
is going to be I don't know if it's
going to be like an XO or like a mini E3
but I do think that we'll see it at the
beginning of the year
it was January they would have just done
it at the game awards yeah totally agree
Aaron see here's the thing though Aaron
I think the reason that the Video Game
Awards is a little
like iffy on how things would have been
with the Video Game Awards is if there
was more than than could have been on
that stage I can understand why it's not
at that stage
so I can understand that
because if they had like
30 minutes of things they needed to show
and they only had like five minute
window in the video at the vgas then why
show anything there when they could just
hold it and show it at their own event
since they need one anyway
January the 16th after court hearing on
the 3rd of January
it's gonna be interesting man all right
I'm gonna say
let me bring up a calendar real quick
when you guys say they normally do these
on like
they wouldn't I think
what day of the week do you think they
would do it on like a Friday or Thursday
because Sony usually has theirs on
Thursdays
they're like little things one was an
Insight let's look at the last inside
Xbox
because we haven't really had anything
like that in a while
now I don't know if it's going to be an
inside Xbox but
let's look at the Gamescom inside Xbox
it was August the 25th 2022.
so it was a Thursday yeah you guys are
right Thursday
I think inside Xbox could work if it was
done correctly
but it's just a matter of doing it
correctly it's
inside Xbox format can work it's just
can they do it correctly can that you
you need you need information
you need the actual games to show
you need the the personalities to
present the information
and I feel like
sometimes they lose
touch on how to present these shows
Monday because they want a week of
people talking about I think they'll
announce it on a Monday
but it won't come out till like that
Thursday so if we go by that let's go to
February
all right so we got
we got February the 2nd the 9th the 16th
and the 23rd
February 2nd 9th 16th 23rd which one do
you guys think it is
I'm going to say
I'm gonna say the ninth February 9th is
when we'll see the event
yeah I think ninth is a good day good
day
good day I'm gonna go back and look at
these guys and you know I'm gonna go
back we're gonna we're gonna make like a
complimation video and everything
posted on IOP find out who was right
you know put that in the comment section
man put that in the comment section
you know let's let's move on though man
we don't need to really stick on these
topics too too much you know 33 minutes
and we talking about Sony block and Xbox
yeah everyone you know
shout out the Hulk hopefully you know he
feels better
you know scared horrible scare man he he
needs to uh
take it easy when he gets back man relax
that's what he needs to do definitely
needs to relax
Sony block and Xbox I told you guys I
said multiple times that Microsoft that
something was going on with Square Enix
in particular
preventing them for bringing those games
over
something was going on and that and
Microsoft came out in this this
thing pretty much agreeing that that's
what's happening I'm streaming
by the way the Baja Blast is terrible
what
foreign
just 156 people
and sorry about that guys my brother
says something's wrong with the ball
place
it's a little weak but it's fine
Sony wants Xbox dead
um
I don't here's the thing Sony's doing
what Sony has to do I don't blame them
what I don't like is how they play
victim about about doing about doing it
that's what I don't like
it's like if you're not going to
if you're not going to do what you have
to do don't
don't blame people man I'll get to that
later
like don't sit there and blame people
for something that you're doing wrong
oh that's good man I'll have to move
along man we have to move along so I can
eat
who timed you out Jacob
someone time you out
I don't know
okay Albert G
can someone explain to me how a trillion
dollar company Microsoft can outbid Sony
for third-party gains being timed
exclusive
sometimes it's not about money
it's about
the relationships that they have and
it's about motives in the end
that doesn't align
for instance if you know Square Enix
wants to eventually be bought by Sony
making these kind of deals would benefit
them the most
and I think that's what you're seeing
here as you're seeing
clear alternative motives
that has an agenda but we don't see the
agenda because we don't have all the
news
so I think that's what you're seeing
here
but anyway
it is what it is when it comes to this I
personally feel like Sony
uh you know they they should stop
getting like trying to have people feel
bad for them
you know you lose Call of Duty you lose
Call of Duty that's that's on you at
this point you know you could have had
it for a guaranteed 10 years but instead
you went on this giant violin
and I don't think it's right
uh maybe score wants to be a more
popular brand in PlayStation that's all
I don't agree with that because then why
why release anything on Xbox at that
point
can you answer that Albert
if that's the point and they want to be
more popular with the Xbox brand I mean
the PlayStation brand why release
anything on Xbox
it makes no sense
that's just my honest opinion it makes
zero sense to do that
yeah I agree 100 I've made videos on my
personal Channel multiple times vampire
that's what they need to do they need to
make their own personal Studios to
combat what's going on there
house we're gonna grow Final Fantasy by
making it exclusive
it's about money money and motives for
what they might want in the future for
their company
that
is
appreciate it uh
appreciate it man you guys have a good
thing too
they need Microsoft needs to go out
and they need to build their own Studios
100 percent
you know and if they don't do that go
and buy companies like you know Sega
build them up there's a lot of things
they can do
they need to do them though and I think
that they do want to it's just this
Activision deal has so much money think
about it the what this way guys
they can lose how much it would cost to
buy activate to buy Sega almost by this
deal not going through
like put that into perspective
they can lose how much it would cost to
buy a company like Sega or close to that
amount
by this deal not going through
and I think that's the biggest reason
that it's they're being very
careful on what they announce
how they present information and I think
that's the key reason because there's a
lot of money riding on this
yeah I agree and I I think we'll start
seeing them
take that more seriously like there's
there's a lot of smaller Indie
developers like Mist Walker I really
love that they would you know work with
Miss Walker right write them a check and
get like another Lost Odyssey made or
another IP in general like it would be
really nice
yeah when does that come out it comes
out sometime this month
uh Capcom I think I obviously Microsoft
could buy Capcom but with Capcom cell I
I don't know
I don't know what they would sell man
I think that was so Sony
the thing
Microsoft needs
companies that they can build up
and that's why I feel like
if they if they do go for a publisher
it's going to be Sega I think Sega would
be the easiest one for them to get and I
think getting
something like
like Persona 6. imagine if they come up
on stage this E3
and they announced persona 6.
and it's a and it's an exclusive on Xbox
and PC and it's in Game Pass
it'd be big it would be huge people
would lose their mind
that need more opportunities like that
and I think that they're going to
eventually look but you know we just
have to get it to it man
what's up hip hop yo Happy New Year just
had to show you some real quick love
addict let's go I need to get you on the
attic show one time hip-hop what's going
on with that man why you being so
elusive hit me slide in my DMs hip-hop
they open slide in them
you know I don't I don't play baseball
or anything I used to when I was a kid
but you know Sly home man slide home
slide straight into the DMs
let's get something going let's get
something going
give Square to them
imagine Twitter
imagine what would happen
if Twitter
what would happen if Microsoft bought
Square Enix
it would be
the craziest day on Twitter
I couldn't even imagine I couldn't even
really
I couldn't even remotely fathom
that day on Twitter if Microsoft bought
Square Enix you would hear me screaming
from the top of my lungs because
I want it to happen I ain't leaving
front you guys man
I want them to come out and just start
swinging you know that's that's why
part of me is concerned with
consolidation
but then the other part of me seeing
PlayStation go out there and timed
exclusive everything under the sun
so at that point
they're consolidating the industry just
not the Developers
they're just getting all the games
oh my God you guys are ridiculous you
guys are ridiculous I love it though I
love it man I love it
I just
I truly want the industry to do better
and I feel like
Sony
they're gonna have to do something you
know Microsoft's gonna have to work with
people like Mr Walker work with people
like not just missed Walker they're
gonna have to work with a few people
they're gonna have to get their own
Japanese branch and I had like a nice
little thought process because I feel
like in order for them to succeed in
that area they're gonna have to have
someone that's got clout in that area
and as much as I don't like his games
had Gino Kojima
is got that clout
so to me a good thing they can do is
they can go to Kojima and be like look
we want to buy Kojima your company
uh but what we want the most
is we want you
to run a publishing unit be like the
Peter Moore of the publishing thing
and they're like we want to bring on
Japanese developers developing Studios
onto this publishing arm and we want you
to run it
um
you know if they bought Sega you know he
could be in charge of that whole thing
he could be the not the uh the dude from
Bethesda like the Matt booty
uh Pete Heinz like he could be that
person in the east
that is bringing that talent to them
because I do think you know he's got a
lot of a lot of influence
he wants to be independent but I think
his ego is huge and if you offered him
something like that I think he'd take it
just think about it he would be one of
the most important people in the East
for Xbox
like he would be the big fish in the
small sea
man you know I can't that's fine see
we
we've established that I can't do that
and it's okay
because I deem it okay and what I deem
okay
is facts it's law at that point
all right so let's let's move on ain't
really a whole lot to talk about with
that man you know there's a lot of
things going on we're gonna see man
we're gonna see so 46 minutes we're
going we we're gonna talk about this for
for a few minutes man
red fall
and Starfield internally being delayed
now Starfield
starfield's not really been internally
delayed it's more about redfall but
if redfall comes out in May like it's
been rumored then you could expect
that means star filled isn't going to
come out until after E3 because May June
well they gonna have it out in June I
mean I guess that's a possibility
but you got Zelda coming around that
area you know I'm sure PlayStation's got
stuff they haven't announced coming out
in that area you got third party stuff
coming out in that area
it's it's a weird thing and what I want
to ask you guys
I want to ask the chat the realm
if Starfield
came out in July would you guys have an
issue with it
I know that's technically past the 12
months that they offered
but I feel like it's not too far off of
that 12 months
I think it would be fine if it came out
early July
that's just me I think it would be fine
all right so
let me just clarify is Yes means you
have a problem and no means you don't
have a problem is that what you guys are
saying
yeah that's what I'm saying July just
July nothing past July I don't I agree
with you guys that we can't get too out
of control
July is the latest it can go it can't go
anything more than July
and I I feel like
here there's some species there's some
conditions to the July release day one
they gotta have a good showing of this
game when it gets the release date when
it gets that that Gameplay trailer it's
got to have a good showing it can't just
come out there and show the gameplay
that we've already seen
and go from there it's got to have a
good showing
it's got to be impressive looking It's
gotta clearly look like it it's it's
improved performance because I know some
people felt like the performance wasn't
good
it's got to have good good presentation
to whatever is shown
two
it cannot under no circumstances be in
E3 to some big form I would prefer it
not even be there but if they want to
show to E3 maybe open the floor with it
and it's really fast
and they show the release date for July
which I think that's too late it's a
month of marketing probably not gonna
happen in July in June but if they
wanted to show a little bit of Starfield
at E3 that's fine but it cannot be
what the game what this the whole event
is rotated around
I would prefer it not be there but if it
has to be there they need to open up
with it get it done quick and move on I
don't want them staying on something
that they've talked about for two other
years besides this year so this would be
the third year
I don't want that you know
we we need to see other stuff at that
event we don't need to see too much
Starfield
what do you guys think you know those
are my conditions I feel like July isn't
bad so like July
now
I would prefer early glitter July but if
any time in July I think would be okay I
would prefer early July
but anything past July is an issue
because
you're coming up like what 14 months you
know maybe this
this particular incident where it needed
a little bit more time I would be a
little bit more lingual with it but part
of me is just like look like you guys
can't come out there
put your stick in the in the dirt and
say no thing after 12 months
and then you you miss it by three months
I I don't I don't agree with that you
know they need to do better on that
and if they're going to come out there
and they're going to say 12 months
I want to see it in 12 months now I feel
like a month isn't a bad thing
as long as the game's good now Starfield
was coming out in July
and it did very well like Metacritic
wise and it was just a fantastic game in
general
I feel like we would be okay with that
you know I feel like
as long as the product is there and if
the product is solid people would not
complain about that
like chat Realm
how bad is it going to be if this game
comes out in July or it comes out
anytime before June and it's buggy it
doesn't work great there's certain
mechanics that don't make sense looks
like it's been rushed
it's gonna be bad
that's why I'm hoping
Starfield got all its T's crossed and
all its eyes dotted they really need
this game to hit home
needs to be hit out of the park
um I just I need this game to do good
and not not just strictly on that I want
the game to do good I think Starfield is
a prime example to show what Bethesda
can do
is they need they need to come out there
and actually show it there's nothing
around it you know people have every
right to be skeptical of Microsoft and
Xbox it just depends on what's going to
actually happen with the brand itself
that's the number one key thing it's
going to depend on that
um the first six months of the year are
gen packed I can understand uh July
Zelda and redfall in May and Diablo in
June too much to compete with plus
Diablo will be there should can't hurt
itself I I feel you on that that's why I
feel like there's a lot of variables
going into this maybe it's not even that
the game isn't done by June they just
gotta delay it just internally delayed
now
let's talk a little bit about
about
hellblade supposedly coming out
in 2023 holiday of 2023 I think someone
said September in the chat I think
that's too soon I think we're probably
looking at like late October early
November
I think that would be the more realistic
date
um
trying to figure out what I could say
I guess I'll just say like I I I believe
it I I think
I think this is a good chance to help
blade hits November I mean not November
but you guys get what I'm saying
hellblade might actually hit that Mark
and come out that day and I think
there's a good chance it does and well
my question to you guys is
you you
realm is
now we don't know when
when Forza comes out I think that's
I would say force is like
late February
early March maybe late March
then you got redfall being a May game
you know I don't know what's going on
with uh that Minecraft game then you got
Starfield coming out probably julyish
and then you have
the Minecraft Legends game coming out
somewhere and then and then you have
hellblade coming out the end of the year
and then four months after hellblade a
vow drops like March of net of 2024 a
vow drops
and then six like three or four months
after that you get something else
dropping like maybe a fable or something
I don't think it's going to be a favor
but you guys get what I'm saying there's
plenty of games and development to see
game that that release date
do you think 2023 is a w
that that's my question to you guys if
they release that new Minecraft game
they released Forza
they released star felt and redfall
this year would that make a good 2023
game uh year
so that's five relatively
good ex games which I don't know the
quality of these games but it's five big
IPS you got stuff they're gonna do with
uh Game Pass obviously you know all Game
Pass is gonna be
a pillar that they stand on all year
they always do it so Game Pass is
definitely going to be there you're
gonna have to woo long stuff so that's
gonna be good for them
so that's what I'm curious about you
guys like you know I personally feel
like that's a solid year
solid year
okay
because I think
I think Starfield in July
hellblade
and we'll say the end of October
beginning of November
redfall in May
Four's in March
and Minecraft maybe in June something
like that I think that's a good year
I think that's a a good year
um your PlayStation got some got some
kickers on you know they got they got
the Spider-Man franchise
so I'm kind of curious how that's going
to go you know definitely they got
Spider-Man 2 coming out they got
they got Final Fantasy 16.
they got they got a lot going on too
it just depends on
on exactly what hits because these games
all these games could come out
if they all write 60s
bad luck
but if they write good
I think it could be a force to be
reckoned with now I'm going to end this
with this this is what we're going to do
uh because I'm about to end the show
here probably in the next 15 minutes
we're going to do a Metacritic because
you guys know I don't take Metacritic
seriously but I think it's a good
gauging conversation all right we're
gonna go through these games and I want
you guys to put in the comment section
where you think they're gonna like we'll
get like you guys know how to do three
point three points
on what you think is going to happen all
right so let's let's start with let's
start with with Forza where you guys
think Forza is going to go in three
points like 87
to what like what is the range that you
guys thinks that Forza is going to have
on Metacritic this year 95 that that
someone said a 70. you're so messy
Linda Master 87 to 90. I would say maybe
even 88 to 91. that's what I would say
or you know 91 to 93 is a pretty good uh
estimation too I could see that I could
see that but I I think it's a low a low
90 late 80a think it can easily get that
all right let's let's move on this
Minecraft Legends game
where you guys think that's gonna go
I'ma say
mid 80s like 85 to 88 that's where I'ma
say leads 85 to 88 for Minecraft
oh you guys hitting low
Minecraft is a big franchise
it is a big franchise
someone
hold up hold up let me move my food
so I can look
and find out when what did Minecraft
dungeons get on Metacritic
Minecraft dungeons
I got you guys in one second guys I
appreciate it appreciate the support man
you guys know I no idea how much the
super chats be helping right now
all right so let me oh 70 you guys might
be on to something
you guys might be on to something I
don't know 72.
I don't know I if I remember I thought I
got a better score than this
yeah you guys might be on to something
all right maybe
I need to cool my Jets on the Minecraft
talk all right
got a five dollar Superman from dawn to
talk if everything hits this year
including all Game Pass deals Arc 2
stalker 2 Etc it will be better than any
game
the uh any year that the PS5 had by uh
had this year by a mile I agree I think
it's going to be a good year
um bained with the 10 Superhead thanks
for the show addict starting the new
year off right here in the realm
and then we have a 10 super trap from
long live the Black Mamba uh according
to Jeff Grubb earlier this year
Microsoft planned to release nine games
in 2023 before redfall starfeldom 4 is a
stalker and a few other games before
delay I think people are too worried I
agree uh you know there's a lot of
aspects that's going on here that people
there is a huge thing where people look
for bad things
um you know sometimes sometimes it's
valid sometimes it's not all right so
horrible okay
Minecraft okay redfall
three point
where's redfall going
I think redfall is going to be an 86 to
89 type of game
redfall
uh what's up Cat Daddy I have high
expectations for gaming in 2023. oh you
guys are hitting me with the lows
well some of you are
I don't think if redfall gets a 90 I
would be happy
because I think Arcane is such a a
studio that has slept on I think they
deserve it but that's just me
Cat Daddy we gotta play some fortnite
man
we got to play some fortnite
when are you free I'm so far behind on
shooting some fools in fortnite I need
help
Nine Lives 80 to 83 I wouldn't be
surprised if it got anything in the 80s
to be honest with you I think anything
in the 80s would be okay for a redfall
but I'm thinking mid 80s that's what I'm
thinking mid 80s
actually it's an XBox exclusive so RK
will get their first 70.
because you know how the media where it
could be
uh there will be a Halo I don't think
the Halo battle royale game comes out
this year I'm gonna be real if you guys
I don't think it comes out this year
has Arcane ever made a multiplayer title
um deathly was technically had some
multiplayer aspects to it but I don't
think they've made a full-blown one here
and I'm always busy for the next two
days but we'll link up all right man all
right
um you know you got my number you know
just call me whenever you good because
currently I'm unemployed uh looking but
I'm unemployed so I got I got time man I
got time you know hey playing games kind
of helps me get all out of uh you know
my mind all right so I think you guys
are on point with that I think redfall
is definitely gonna get in that range
in mid 80s I think that's fair I think
mid 80s I'm hoping I'm wrong I'm hoping
to think it's a 90 plus you know it'd be
crazy Chad
what happens if all these games got 90
pluses what happens if redfall got a 91.
Forza got a 91 or 90.
and Starfield got like a 95.
what happens
if that happens
that's not going to happen
you guys are ridiculous
you are ridiculous can we give someone a
little bit
of uh we gotta assume the great man
let's get people the benefit of the
doubt they could come in there
and they can really do a number like
let's let's be fair let's be fair
Sony fans would go crazy
the gaming media never lets that happen
all right
chat
Realm
what is Starfield gonna score
I'm saying that 88 to 91.
that's my personal opinion 88 to 91.
88 to 91.
88 to 91. 95 to 100 you really uh aiming
for the Stars aren't you
foreign
yeah I think that's the biggest thing
Cat Daddy
if I think even if it comes out a little
buggy it just it cannot come out 76
Style buggish
it's got to come out and run
functionally well even if it's a little
buggy as long as the game's good people
will ignore that I know that sounds bad
but that's just how it is
what I want the 95 I expect an 85
I really like death Loop I beat Death
Loop and I actually reviewed death loop
it's on the channel
you know that's back before I was really
breaking games down to the extent that I
break them down now but there's there's
a review on the on this channel for
death loop I did review it
I will be reviewing these other games
too so
it'll be around for 10 years after the
mall gets they ignore Horizon bugs but
we'll do the same for Xbox games uh
I feel you I I do understand where
you're coming from there I don't think
that the media
I do think
I don't know that got a point there
there was a lot of issues that that game
had and I talked to people that was
reviewing it and they said they have no
idea how people didn't do that
did you see smooth's video which one he
made a couple Mark which one
I made the thumbnails for those videos
in case you guys didn't know that I made
the thumbnails for those videos
Xbox even Ragnarok Ragnarok was it
was not a nine game I'm sorry it was a
high eight 87 88
the fact that it scored so high is
beyond me
if we are talking about I think the
biggest thing would be frank rates yeah
it better be 60. there better be
performance mode or I will go play it
somewhere else I'm not gonna lie I will
go play it on PC if there's not a
performance mode on Xbox series X
if it's not a solid third person game
it'll get a lower score
attic Hellboy two all right all right
all right
we'll do it
we'll do it just because you brought it
up nine lives
Realm
where is Hell Blake getting I'm saying
90 to a 93.
90 to a 93 is what hellblade's gonna get
it shout out to uh two dollars Super
Chat from txr 1138 redfall in Starfield
on Game Pass metal or not
yeah but you know
if I didn't have food to eat I would
bring up
my issue with that statement because I
got a big issue with that statement uh
but I don't got time to really talk
about it right now
yeah
you know I don't ever like to like
completely
juice up King but he he's not he's not
entirely wrong that does feel like a big
ass DLC
I think how Blade's gonna I think how
Blake's gonna score well I do I think
that they have made that game to be
visually impressive
uh let's just hope that they can improve
on some of the aspects that the first
one didn't have uh to this day I haven't
been hell uh hellblade
um
it's really hard for me to play that
game because of the
because of like the mental aspect that
they have on that game
yeah see that's what I'm saying that
Audio Man
it's creepy it's the creepiest game I've
ever played when it comes to how they do
audio
I will mentally can't play it it bothers
me
what did Corey say that you said facts
facts facts Sony games get the benefit
of the doubt industry is afraid to score
I never trust
um
you can't finish Hellboy one but no how
the reason I can't finish whole blade
one is just more of like me issues it's
not the game it's me
like when she starts like talking
and like whispering in your ears and
[ __ ] that bothers me man like
it just like goes down my spine it's
thinking about it bothers me
I'd like to see Ninja Theory do a sequel
to Odyssey of the West to the West Ninja
3 is a very unique Studio that can do a
lot more than people think
pretty sure two won't be won't be yeah
I'm pretty sure it's going to be about
the same it feels like that's the
biggest thing that
they play off of is just you know her
mind and the the mental issue she has
I don't agree with that entirely Dawn
otaku um I feel like 2018 was was
justified for its I think it was a a 94
95 but I don't think Ragnarok was the
same quality as 18. I think 18 was a
better game in almost every aspect and I
do feel like
I do feel like there is some truth
behind some people are too scared to
write PlayStation certain things because
we've seen PlayStation kind of get a
little bit trigger friendly with not
sending people review codes because they
didn't review it they didn't do it as
good on the last ones
uh play it through TV speakers a headset
will have you sleep with the lights on
yo I see maybe I need to do that but
here's the thing Cat Daddy I
I feel like I'm selling out if I play
that through the speakers
because the game wasn't designed to play
through the speakers
yeah well see here's the thing
I'm never gonna agree to how they run
that I feel like
the industry should go
we give you a review code
and you review the game
and we get the feedback to make another
one
but I feel like
it's not ran like that
I feel like
people use PR firms and companies
use
that aspect
because what they want to do
is they want to use
certain creators that they know
okay
I will say that I feel like sometimes
people are censored and they don't get
review codes because they know that they
are wild cards
and I think that is a huge issue in the
industry
I'm not going to say it's a big issue
and Rocco say it happens all the time
and I'm not gonna say every publishing
unit or every developer does it but I do
feel like
I feel like the aspect
that goes on
is bad when it comes to that
because what I see
is I see big content creators
that are normally very vocal about how
they tell stuff
I see them getting
not getting review codes and stuff but I
see people that are very positive in
everything they say in the industry and
nothing's ever wrong and they're always
getting review codes
so I there's got to be a reason that's
happening
and at the end of the day it's not the
pr firm's fault they're gonna go with
whatever the the industry lets them
it's just it's just interesting how
things go and I feel like
being an influencer that especially that
reviews games
it's a rough thing because at any time
a review that you're not feeling that
you put a review out for
and you go in on a game
can cause you to lose aspects of your
company
to review games for that studio from
there going on out
soon because to get
I don't know if well here's the thing
though
do I think Sony sometimes punishes
people for saying certain things yes
but what I will say
is I don't think that their games are
too far off of the reviews they got
a war ragnarok's one of the funeral wild
that I felt like it got too high
I think right I think both Horizons
scored what they were supposed to
I think 2018 Squirtle was supposed to I
do think Last of Us Part Two should have
been a couple points down but I can
understand why someone would vote it
there
being a 90 to a 95 in the industry
should be so much harder to get than it
is
I feel like seeing a game review as a 10
out of 10
should be a rarity but it seems like all
these games are always getting 10 out of
10.
[Music]
can you search your interests of the
Love Letter live on stream
uh man I'm trying to eat Donald taco
what do you want me to stream
Grand
trismo 7.
love letter
are we talking about a video donataku
are we talking about
like an article
because I'm gonna be real if you don't
want to talk him
I'm not I'm not reading I'm eating
I'll be real with you I'm eating
last of our two deserved its score
that's one I'll give him Lies Over twos
no just the search results
uh
sure
I guess donataka
why not
so
why not all right so the this is what
Donna taku dessert felt like we needed
to see
Gran Turismo Love Letter grandchild
seven is a love letter to call culture
I mean is that wrong though I know they
had a lot of microtransactions that
messed up a lot of aspects to the game
but is it wrong
you know just because the
microtransactions really
bothered people I don't think that means
that it's not a love letter to the car
culture but I don't I don't do nothing
with cars so I wouldn't know either
a love letter to Gran Turismo
oh geez are you saying everything's a
love letter is that what you're saying
yeah I feel you they're all saying the
same thing
that's kind of crazy
wow
you might be on to something they're
doing a taco you might be on to
something there
sure they're not duplicates I know
they're all different websites
we need I really like the old Need For
Speed Most Wanted the one that was on
the 360. you guys know the one that we
had you had to fight your way up The
Blacklist thing
The Blacklist list I really enjoyed that
game where the dude took your your uh
I'm not a car dude I can't I don't know
what vehicle he took from him but he
took that blue and white car at the
beginning and he and he used it to fight
his way up and you got out of jail he
was number one
do was 15 at the beginning of the game
stole your ride and used it to get
number one
a BMW M3 I think
I can't remember what it was
but that's the best Need for Speed I've
ever played by far and I remember they
remade it and it was trash it was
nothing like the original one
man I think that's on Xbox
I think that's on Xbox
Racing for slips oh I love that man I
remember there was a Porsche Need For
Speed Most Wanted I would race because
you had to like pick the the tickets and
one of them is this uh is the The
Blacklist uh the the pink slips and I
remember racing him multiple times until
I got his pink slips
that was good man that was good I really
enjoyed that but I'm gonna go ahead and
uh head out here man I appreciate
everyone coming through I'll have this
uh up on the SoundCloud uh on Spotify
and that in a couple
probably in a day I think will be I
ain't gonna front you guys it'll be a
little bit but I appreciate everyone
coming through man you guys have a good
day you know
Tuesday we'll be back uh hopefully I
don't know I haven't talked to King uh
most likely maybe Tuesday we'll be back
with RNR I won't be doing attic show
because this is the attic show for this
week I'm not doing two
and the next Sunday we're coming back on
IOP and you know we're going to talk
about a lot of the info that's been
dropping throughout the break the
two-week break we had
uh but you know we've been doing this
for about an hour and 20 minutes my
food's been cold it's sitting here cold
look what you guys did to me
what you guys did to me
but I appreciate you ever come through
and until next time the